over the course of more than two dozen
appearances on the adult swim series tim
and eric awesome show
great job john c reilly bewildered and
delighted audiences
as the unforgettable dr steve bruhl who
offered viewers life tips in a segment
called rules rules i'm dr steve bruhl
with another brule rule for you if
you're raking the leaves and it gets all
of your driveway just hose it off dummy
the character proved so popular
that tim high decker eric werheim and
riley spun off the character into his
own series
check it out with dr steve bruhl here's
just about everything there is to know
about dr brule
check it out birth of a dingus
in early 2006 this unlikely trio of
collaborators met at a bowling alley
during a birthday party for comedian and
actor ron lynch
who appeared in tim and eric's cult hit
cartoon show time goes to the mayor
at the time john c rowley was already a
well-respected character actor
who even earned an oscar nomination for
chicago the three hit it off
and high decker and werheim invited
reilly to be on their show
riley accepted the invitation playing a
crazed version of himself that tom meets
on a social networking site
called friendship alliance tom no
no no no no no
no no time goes to the mayor wrapped up
a few months later
and tim and eric moved on to their next
show riley arrived with costume and
character in tow
eric wareheim later told reddit bruhl
was john's idea completely
he improvises most if not all of what he
does
he even brought his own outfit along
with the hair to the show
hi decker and weyerheim just set riley
free to do what he wanted
in 1971 bill grates invented microsoft
wouldn't it be cool if i could remember
my dingus password for my email
that would be cool rule
is real we know that dr steve bruhl is
portrayed by john c
riley or izzy john that's clearly you
no he was wearing glasses going in riley
has insisted that his relationship to
bruhl
is as executive producer of check it out
and that he's never even met the doctor
in person
um are you trying to say that you're not
doctor steve brawl the dog just steve
no he's a doctor however riley will
occasionally let the veil
slip he told esquire that he didn't
really create the character
as much as he just showed up for an
awesome show taping saying
he started channeling that guy i don't
know where he came from
i think of them as real and anytime i
start to analyze them
it gets really boring some things are
just better left mysterious
i'm not really interested in picking it
apart
okay gotcha check it out
doctor to doctor the brule experience is
more than just john c
riley and check it out he interviews
business owners
craftspeople athletes artists and more
if they seem uncomfortable they're not
faking it senpai decker told
entertainment weekly that they're all
completely real
saying the comedy is not necessarily
about fooling these people it's more the
character of steve bruhl being
completely clueless and a really strange
guy
well yeah pretty hair like a lady
thank you
tim mirrored the same sentiments that
eric expressed in his reddit ama
they don't want to make the participants
the butt of the joke but they want their
genuine reactions
the confusion of the guests is
heightened riley says by the show's lack
of pre-interviews
when viewers see bruhl talk to people
they're really encountering one another
for the first time
for denny's sake watching the hands come
out well all this talk about chips is
making me hungry
dang give me some chips throughout check
it out dr brewell barks at a guy known
only as
denny denny you're dirtbag mugger guy
you're gonna come and i'm gonna keep you
off of my case man
according to riley denny's the person
that does the technicals
he's responsible for the sound camera
work and editing
the reason he doesn't seem to be
particularly good at any of it
is because denny has a lot of
old danny in the workshop making all the
ddv's for you
dingoes another one of denny's jobs is
being steve's handler
furthering the illusion that dr steve
and john c reilly aren't the same person
riley and his collaborators say they get
in touch with bruhl by
paging denny denny then faxes steve and
then steve
sends a fax back to denny bagboy
in 2015 adult swim aired a dr steve
bruhl special called
bagboy presented as a sitcom pilot
created by and starring bruhl
as an inept grocery store worker it
wasn't really written by bruhl of course
but by tim eric and riley
before they began highdecker researched
real supermarket set sitcoms to nail
down the characteristics
as it turns out there haven't been too
many but the first and most prominent
one high decker could find was a 1980s
canadian sitcom
starring don adams its title
[Music]
bag boy was based heavily on 1980s check
it out
down to the attractive checkout girl and
the inept security guard
and the rest is very weird history
for your health dr bruhl is no stranger
to monkeys
what kind of animal you want to be
dingus probably a dog
nope no that's not it
you'd be a dangatang that's what you
look like and in the 2017 blockbuster
kong skull island
riley plays an air force lieutenant
named hank marlow
who's been stranded on skull island for
three decades
the movie also features what's got to be
an allusion to dr
steve bruhl riley's character wears his
old military jacket
which displays the name of his squadron
along with the words
good for your health that can't be a
coincidence right
pure health for your health for your
health
rules rules there's one big lingering
question about dr steve bruhl
how does this guy have a doctorate in
anything
i don't have to say anything i'm a
doctor too
according to riley's reddit interview
bruhl just might not be a doctor at all
he revealed that his mother may have
actually named him dr
stephen bruhl but it wouldn't be the
weirdest thing his mother did to him
i got locked in a basement
[Music]
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love too